[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir à tous ça va moi j'écoute offre
conjointe le club d'élite des microbes
ou microgouttes naples et sa d'un titre
alors moi je vais vous parler d'un sujet
à la mode donc le smartphone vous savez
ce petit objet qu un peu la
réincarnation de gimmicks riquet donc
pinocchio donc il vient faciliter nos
existences jusque dans ses moindres
détails
michael stora spécialiste des addictions
l'appelle d'ailleurs lé doute ou sans
fil est désormais ce qui est nouveau
c'est qu'il entend faire de nous des
acteurs responsables capables de
résoudre les défis climatiques et
sociaux qui ces derniers temps a
violemment à notre porte
donc on voit débarquer sur le devant de
la scène des services numériques mobiles
qui entendent améliorer nos modes de vie
ce qui change c'est qu'ils ne le font
plus uniquement pour notre bien-être
personnel mais revendique une
responsabilité sociale et
environnementale
on les appelle les services numériques à
un pacte donc en gros le smartphone
serait un peu la nouvelle lampe d'aladin
capable de résoudre la crise climatique
et ces collatéraux a juste ici tout est
au mieux dans le meilleur des mondes
sauf que on commence à entendre des
petites voix des lanceurs d'alert comme
le dirt scientifique michel desmurget
nos théoriciens ici ton qui commence à
nous parler du frein au développement
cognitif représenté par l'addiction aux
smartphones il nous parle également de
théorie de la tension dix ans à dire que
c'est le temps qu'on passe sur ses
services qui est le nouvel or noir de
leur créateur ces gardiens de phare de
notre rapport au numérique nous parle
terre de l'impatience est assistanat
généralisée alors oui ça fait peur mais
il ya quelque chose
on doit garder en mémoire le smartphone
et même le numérique dans son ensemble
ce sont des intentions humaine et nous
sommes coresponsables de l'utilisation
qu'on en fait la vraie question du coût
sous-tendu n'est t'elle pas comment
conserver la lucidité et la cohérence
pour rester maîtres des deux équipes
dans ton sens tours sans se départir
d'une vision long terme et de notre
volonté d'oeuvrer pour le bien commun et
déjà en sommes nous capables alors moi
de mon côté je suis pas du tout un
lanceur d'alerté j'ai passé 10 ans à
travailler dans le numérique
donc j'ai un contrô les mains dans le
cambouis pour vouloir mettre le feu au
bien être ma dernière aventure
entrepreneuriale consiste d'ailleurs une
application mobile qui veut aider les
gens de manière ludique à comprendre et
à adopter des gestes éco responsables
sauf que j'ai la fâcheuse tendance à
tout remettre en question
et donc après deux ans de travail sur
cette application
certains paradoxes du digital impact
vous commencez à vous de chiffonner et
je vous propose qu'on les évoquent
ensemble ce soir le premier paradoxe les
services numériques à un pacte nous
déresponsabilise tout en faisant porter
sur chacun d'entre nous la résolution
des grands enjeux collectifs du siècle
alors on l'a vu ces services il modifie
la manière dont on s'alimente dont on se
déplace dans sa vie on se chauffe et
même dont on vient en aide aux
populations fragiles ils fonctionnent
comme des assistants personnels de
comportement responsable des
applications d'un citadin y en a plein
mais qui ne concernent jusqu'ici que
notre bien-être personnel méditation
nutrition sport et en voulant contrer
dans la résolution comme jeu collectif
ils font porter sur chacun d'entre nous
cette résolution nous disent en gros
c'est nos modes de vie qui sont la cause
de la crise que nous traversons
et c'est en les changeant que nous
allons trouver la solution
le moi si on me dit ça on dit en gros je
suis coupable
et si juste de ces coupables et que jean
un fait plutôt avoir tendance à baisser
la tête et à rester dans l'action plutôt
que de m'indigner et de vouloir changer
les choses on nous déresponsabilise en
parlant on nous responsabilisons
justement sur ses causes profondes
ils nous disent une chose c'est qu'il
faut qu'il y ait justement donc nos
disques du faut qu'il y ait débat par
andres acte de communication que toute
la jonction permanente âge car ils
passent leur temps à nous dire d'agir et
comment le faire
donc la question c'est comment conserver
la lucidité
c'est bien de le dire et voilà un petit
mitron donnez moi c'est un prestige les
sous traitants congrès je vais passer
directement deuxième paradoxe ça ira ça
ira encore mieux les services numériques
intacte utilisent les mêmes mécaniques
qui ont généré les excès du combattent
aujourd'hui dans ce qu'on pourrait
appeler la société numérique critiques
qu'on peut dire qu'on vit par le jeu
appelle ça d'ailleurs là une
modification donc challenge jauger pour
une progression bâche de succès notation
partage automatisé du rouergue
ces petites composantes apparemment
anodine ont d'importants effets
cognitifs
alors je vous propose qu'on prenne un
peu de hauteur pour comprendre justement
pourquoi cette couse double explication
fonctionne si bien sûr lanceur de
l'histoire de l'humanité
nous avons vécu 90 % du temps en tant
que chasseur cueilleur new man et moins
de 10% avec une agriculture sédentaires
et la capacité de prospective et
d'anticipation du futur 10%
ce n'est pas assez pour que notre
cerveau s'adapte à ce nouvel angle
et la vie de chasseurs cueilleurs
nomades ll était simple son seul
répétées de survivre pour ce faire il
devait identifier et mémoriser et
comportements qui pouvait le mieux mieux
l'aider à survivre et pour cela il a
développé un moyen infaillible qui
s'appelle tout bêtement la dopamine
l'hormone du plaisir et de la récompense
ans sébastien polaire qui a une ronde
biologiste a identifié cinq grands
comportement qui explique qu'ils sont
valorisés dans notre cerveau par la
dopamine le fait d'accumuler de séduire
d'acquérir du pouvoir de la
reconnaissance sociale de collecter le
maximum d'informations sur notre
environnement et de faire tout cela avec
le moins d'effort possible donc
maintenant regardons si vous voulez bien
la couche de guémy fication de la
plupart des applications quand je fais
ce qui est préconisé dans l'app
d'ailleurs dès que je m'inscris je suis
immédiatement récompensés par lectra
donc là je vous demande d'imaginer les
yeux exorbités le sourire béat d'un
joueur au casino qui vient mettre ces
dommages aux biens tels que sur tapis
vert pour collecter les jetons qui vient
de gagner
c'est un réflexe un tri dans notre
cerveau depuis des millénaires et il est
hautement addictif ensuite tout je
totalise deux points puis mon niveau
augmente dans la hiérarchie des
utilisateurs de l'application
je peux même dans un joyeux esprit de
compétition amicale m'ont posé à
d'autres utilisateurs via des défis des
challenge
si je gagne je rejoins les leaders du
monde et devient à potentiel partenaire
attractif
est ce que ça ne me rappelle pas les
mécanismes de sélection des individus à
el fâcher
l'aca ensuite on nous propose des micros
objectif très facilement atteignable on
me met le pied à l'étrier de l'éco
responsabilité tout en nous tout en nous
sortant
donc je scroll je clique je rentre mon
mec je vais une étoile est déjà en notre
est licite alors moins très
naturellement j'ai déjà l'impression
d'être un acteur responsable alors que
je n'ai rien fait dans la vraie vie donc
sans le moindre effort et là paf chose
de notable
et enfin on va m'envoyer des tonnes de
petites brèves des snacks informationnel
comme guide du type le savait qu il faut
3 litres d'eau pour fabriquer une
bouteille en plastique de 50 centilitres
c'est sur ces informations un imac
tant qu'on n'est pas une moyenne tout
comme c'est le cas aujourd'hui nous a
appris à croire que ce un crime ou 140
caractères permettait maîtriser un sujet
les concepteurs d'ap vous rétorqueront
oui il ya la fonction
en savoir plus est-ce que vous cliquez
sur la fonction savoir plus moi non et
c'est normal parce que mon cerveau est
un doux mine d'informations parce
qu'auparavant c'est ce qui lui
permettait de survivre dans un
environnement où il y en avait très peu
en tant que chasseur cueilleur s'il
voyait mon voisin de venir pouvaient
après avoir ingéré une baie rouge
je veux pas la manger et je passer à la
suite sauf que dans cette offre car
quand tu es cette information que nous
avons aujourd'hui a surgi un nouveau
problème que dominique wolton chercheur
au cnrs appel l'horizon de la
communication visant à dire que
paradoxalement plus on a d'information
mois on communique le souci c'est que la
communication
et puis une compétence primordial pour
résoudre des hanches ou collectif sans
elle on privilégie des réflexes à la
réflexion et bref la gym sans y penser
alors là je n'aimerais pas qu'on fasse
une petite parenthèse sur la notion d
bon peut-être certains d'entre vous
connaissent qui montre qu'en fait c'est
rarement un cynisme conscient ces
dérives de la part des concepteurs
d'applications des plutôt une mauvaise
anticipation de la croissance les héros
noirs
c'est l'effet de surconsommation générés
par le fait de repousser des limites
grâce à une innovation souvent
technologique
je vais vous donner un exemple si je
télécharge une application d'anti
gaspillage alimentaire qui nous propose
d'acheter des invendus de la grande
distribution qui sinon finirait à la
poubelle
moi je dis banco chez un acteur
responsable je fais une bonne action
mais en faisant cela je ne nuisent pas à
la consommation je la légitime et par
là-même gdj team un système de
surproduction et de répartition inégale
des ressources alimentaires sur la
planète il faut pas oublier que derrière
la notion de comportement responsable
bien forcément une notion de sobriété de
frein à la consommation
et paradoxalement tous ses services
numériques vous pousse à leur
utilisation
ce qui en soi est une contradiction le
troisième paradoxe vient un peu en
conclusion des deux précédents nous
avons pu créer une société capable
d'harmonie d'action commune iii de sony
dyke mail usages actuels du numérique
montre que nous sommes pas encore
capables différents l'origine d'internet
à l'époque de la cybernétique et du
mouvement post hippie
prenez un numérique capable rendant
capable tout le monde de participer et
de contribuer à la connaissance
il voulait par exemple que nous
puissions mobilisés en prenant
connaissance de problèmes partout dans
nos jeux numériques à l'époque il était
libre ouvert et autorégulé aujourd'hui
quatre acteurs détiennent 80% des
données personnelles de l'humanité ce
qui montre que
nous ne sommes pas encore capable
d'habileté le numérique et d'en faire un
outil le bien commun il a été conçu pour
être alors je vais peut-être un peu
déprimé une fois quarante six buts parce
que le numérique a un impact positif
vraiment responsable il existe il serait
1000 partout mais on ne le voit pas car
il est en action dans des collectivités
ont des communautés aussi petite soit
elle il est re devenu un outil local
endémique ingles à la fois dans ses
ambitions et dans son utilisation
la solution saas est peut-être arrivé à
la synchronisation des maturités et on y
arrive qu'un cas d'al côté le numérique
a fini sa généralisation
et comment son autocritique de l'autre
nous en tant qu'espèce on sort tant bien
que mal de l'adolescence et de ses
pulsions hormonal des greens et donc ce
numérique responsable si vous voulez
trouver
je vous conseille d'aller voir ailleurs
ailleurs ça veut souvent dire
à l'opposé de la boutique ça se passe
parce que c'est tout naturel on regarde
ce nom là où ça brille mais on lui de
regarder là où ça resserre donc la
prochaine fois qu'on lui dit aspyr toit
de la silicon valley d'aller en creuse
où dédié rien n'était au numérique
viennent retisser le lien social
d'éviter dans un milieu relégué si on
nous dit parce qu'une qu'à la station
elf fait le grand activateur de start up
à paris la ligue tauromachie le
numérique sert à revivifier les
traditions et la culture malienne
si on vous dit tu as vu la dernière
licorne vous savez le club des livres
des start-up valorisée 1 milliard de
dollars est bien lorgner plutôt du côté
des low tech qui pour qu'il prône une
utilisation raisonnée des technologies
et enfin si on vous rebat les oreilles
avec la start up nation d'un procès
juste à l'élan de solidarité né des
réseaux sociaux qui ont conduit des
milliers de jeunes dans la rue pour le
climat donc oui on peut être optimiste
quant au devenir de
l'utilisation du numérique on peut
peut-être même l'être quand on devenir
de l'humanité mais un optimisme
conscient vigilante qui est conscient de
nos faiblesses de nos penchants naturels
et s'évertue à les maîtriser
alors pas de manière cartésienne on a
voulu on a essayé de dominer la nature
et dans la reprit le boomerang en pleine
tronche
non un optimisme qui est fait de bon
sens pour nous permettre d'être toujours
aussi créatifs passionnés allant de
l'avant mais vraiment au service de tous
merci de votre attention
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]